[Musique]
on mettra gâtés en érection parmi les
élections fédérales lui ont fait de
l'ombre à ce qu'on peut compter soit
faite
et la campagne municipale est bel et
bien commencé bonjour à tous les
citoyens de plus deux mois de juin par
rapport
vous savez que c'est aux municipales que
la majorité des décisions qu'on prend on
beaucoup d'un facteur est à longueuil la
course se joue à quatre oui bonjour
madame je m'appelle maxime charron pour
la collection longue et catherine
fournet l'ancien péquiste devenue
députée indépendante dans marie-victorin
catherine fournier mise sur la diversité
mais surtout la nouveauté donc je pense
que les gens ont vraiment envie d'un
renouveau à la ville de longueuil après
les années un peu plus difficile sur le
plan des mechs cannes malheureuse au
comptant les séances houleuses la saga
de l'abattage des chevreuils
ou encore le salaire élevé de la
mairesse sortante
on va avoir également 50% valeur de la
mairesse parce qu'on a fait l'actualité
un peu trop la candidate josé
latendresse veut aussi en finir avec les
controverses c'est décevant
effectivement c'est elle se représente
après avoir perdu par quelques centaines
de voix en 2017 quand on fait les choses
une deuxième fois a mis seulement ont
fait mieux dans les dernières années on
a beaucoup vu un top dingue c'est plus
confiants qu'on fait de la politique on
a beaucoup bu aussi de la politique
partisane on travaille plus comme ce
genre et pour nos candidats à la mairie
de longueuil
l'ancien président de la csn lui a
choisi la continuité
il se présente pour action longueuil le
parti de l'ancienne mairesse caroline
st-hilaire et de la mairesse sortante
sylvie parent ville comme longueuil
studio smashing avec des enjeux qui sont
déjà lors environnement transports
collectifs habitations abordables
destruction des petites maisons
transformation d'une ville qui à said se
positionne en termes de développement
économique dont tu peux pas dire je mets
le compteur à zéro je recommence une
pointe à peine voilée à celle qui semble
être en tête catherine fourni et qui
s'attire déjà les foudres de ses
opposants comme le candidat jean marc
léveillé c'est quelqu'un qui est qu'un
mail 5 heures d'expérience une marche ce
travail qui aspirent à gérer 800
millions de budget
anciennement la tête de l' orchestre
symphonique de longueuil gestionnaire et
entrepreneurs de carrière il se lance en
politique avec le parti longue et
citoyens le parti de l'opposition
c'est un conte est déjà certain qu'ils
s'intéressent à gérer les affaires
publiques son plus grand défi se fait
reconnaît qu'actuellement ce qu'il est
en train de me préoccupe c'est que c'est
les médias montréal qui vont décider qui
sont les candidats la ville de longueuil
puis ça ça commence à me fatiguer pas
mal fort mais au delà de la notoriété de
catherine fournier je veux qu'on est
quand même marché l'assimilé il y encore
beaucoup de travail assure son directeur
de campagne qui la suit depuis plusieurs
amis à la plus exposée que tous les
autres candidats réunis ensemble ils les
vendent et si de plus en plus se décide
à nous appuyer donc on espère que d'ici
le mois de novembre ça continue de cette
manière là bonjour bonjour
au final tous les candidats s'entendent
sur un point le travail sur le terrain
est essentiel aux municipales alors que
le taux de participation n'était que de
33% en 2017 jean que le tour mots d'où
l'importance de faire campagne jusqu'à
la fin issigeac audrey charbonneau raid
au canada longuet